[Music]
foreign
good morning Mr Phelps
this is your mission should you choose
to accept it
should you or any member of your IM
force be caught or killed the secretary
will disavow all knowledge of your
actions
Ethan Hunt will be your point man as
usual good luck Jim
simple game
is he serious always
much worse music
we're being ambushed abort that's in
order
they knew they knew we were coming
do you read me I don't care how he did I
want to know why he did it you're
worried about me
why you survived I'm sure we can find
something I have that you need
these guys are trained to be ghosts
let's not waste time chasing after him
just make him come to us find something
that's personally important to him and
you squeeze
foreign
[Music]
thank you
agent locator
[Music]
good morning Mr Hunt sorry I barged in
on your vacation
well Mr Hunt I don't quite know where to
begin
you know no
should I she's got no training for this
kind of thing to go to bed with a man at
night time she's a woman she's got all
the training she needs
welcome to Australia mate this ain't
funny
the mother of all nightmares is under
loose I don't think I can do it I mean
it'll be difficult
[Music]
well this is not Mission difficult Mr
Hunt it's Mission Impossible
we're supposed to be a walk in the park
for you
[Music]
you gotta be kidding
construct in five seconds
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
such a nice car
it's hot
I know it's hot
foreign
blew up the Kremlin
the president has initiated Ghost
Protocol
the entire IMF has been disappeared
now I've been ordered to take you to
Washington where they will hang the
Kremlin bombing on you and your team
unless you would have escaped after
assaulting Brant and me
any one of your team caught
the brand of terrorists out to incite
Global nuclear war
so what happens now
your mission should you choose to accept
it
so what's the play
[Music]
who are you really Brant we all have our
secrets
don't we Ethan
okay now remember blue is blue and when
it's red dead
you're not gonna make it you're not
helping
[Music]
the IMF is uniquely trained and highly
motivated
specialist without equal immune to any
countermeasures but it is an agency of
chaos
the time has come to dissolve the IMF
now I want you to choose your next words
very carefully
where is hunt
thus I heard he was tracking The
Syndicate
how come the CIA has never discovered
any intel regarding this Syndicate you
want to play an answer for the truth
we've never met before right the farming
veggie Ethan Where Are You The Syndicate
is real a rogue Nation trained to do
what we do an anti-imf
they're coming after us with everything
they've got you ready
this may very well be our last mission
let's make it count
so what's the play
you want to bring down the Syndicate
it's impossible
[Music]
okay
how do you know we can trust her
[Music]
Professor times
Desperate Measures
you got your seatbelt on you asking me
that now
oh hey boys what did I miss
[Music]
Ethan
open the door open the door yeah I'm
trying
[Music]
oh my God
thank you
your mission
should you choose to accept it
I wonder
did you ever choose not to
[Music]
the end you always feared is coming
and the blood will be on your hands
Fallout of all your good intentions
over millions
this world is at risk this is the cia's
mission if he had held on to the
plutonium we wouldn't be having this
conversation this team would be dead yes
they would that's the job
the victim
s
[Music]
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away please
don't make me go through you how many
times has Hans government betrayed him
disavowed him cast him aside how long
before a man like that has had enough
wow
Ethan that's not Who We Are
considered
[Music]
so
how is he oh you know same old Ethan
find it best not to look
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
and we cannot escape the past
Ethan this mission of yours
it's gonna cost you
dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too if anything happens to them there's
no place that I won't go to kill you
that is written
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
thank you